hi this is what to do
hi my name is markiplier I'm here joined
by ether Ethan this is even crazy 9
crank gameplay this is Tyler and we are
gonna do something really nice today God
so we're gonna be doing something nice
something really like fun
it's more of a crap thing it's nails
nails so the history of nails are there
on you before you're born and they grow
forever calcium makes them stronger and
they're like bones alright yes oh yeah
Pablo Picasso you know you love him what
was his first canvas his thumb nail
right here I mean it was his thumbnail
not mine
but you get it he looked at himself and
he said you know I want to start making
art but I don't want to go big first
I'll start smaller and work my way up
and so he went to work little by little
making his perfect little masterpiece on
his now until one day he said hey this
might be nice all the time don't laugh
at history it's not funny it's very
serious he's dead now don't be
disrespectful anyway he said hey that
might be nice to do all the time so he
went out and people saw his nails and
when Pablo how could you do this without
telling her
if Pablo said ideas me cuz he's banished
and they said Pablo Pablo Pablo you've
really outdone yourself this time and he
said see I have and then from then on it
was history everyone is doing there now
it's just like Pablo and just like the
Pablo before him and you know that's
really where it came from and there you
have it everybody that's the sinks a
train okay so we got nail stuff here in
front of us
I've never done my nails but my mom
doesn't yell art and she has decorated
my nails in a great way before I don't
remember how that happened but I take
nothing from that but we have stuff here
it's been carefully picked out
everything we need to make fantastic
nail art is right here these are the
rules you only have to decorate one hand
but it has to have a theme or at least
you need to explain the theme what it is
what you're trying to accomplish it's
okay if you don't have like a lot of
artistic ability so we're not looking
for like drawings on the nail but that's
have a theme across the entire hand make
sense and that's it you can use whatever
you want we have ten minutes and then
after the ten minutes we will judge
makes sense makes sense can I get 10
minutes on the clock imagine to get a
rough really ground hitting it down into
a fine powder get a really powdery right
now I think that's a good first step I
want the pigment of my nail to mix with
the polish and really shine through
I know I know this this uh this is
supposed to hurt cuz you got a push you
gotta like push your cuticles back or
something like that I think that I
remember my mom doing this and I was
like this is oral I'll shut up you big
baby
[Applause]
what is this what is this what what is
this well it says that what they're on
the Box away I can't uh what is this
what is this look at dog shut up I'm
going to go with this holographic walk
shake it up first
oh yes my nails are going to look good
I'm gonna do good there's multiple
colors in this one I'm sorry specific oh
yeah that's good I think to Marble you
need like more than one color just magic
Beauty grace everything above why is
there like a film on the top what is
this
I've got a good start it's gonna clean
this not like substance off of my other
fingers so you know this is the start
how much time do we have all right three
minutes guys go hyperspeed you don't
have time we're gonna have time to go
around anywhere Oh
my fault oh my god it was so good I
don't believe it was good before anyway
what the heck okay look at mine yeah I
don't wanna look at your I'm talking to
you okay yeah my nails look like a
toddler all right I'm good what's the
time one I think as far as the theme
goes Ethan's got a theme down you just
thought of all these sexy nail polish
yeah that's a theme I went way above and
beyond I call it a well marble to
Christmas marble real hard to do cuz it
gets real sticky on the top it kind of
wrapped around my finger in terms of
like overall quality is pretty good
right I think it's pretty good and you
don't look happy
there's no content all right fair enough
I don't all right so explain yours well
I didn't finish mine but it was gonna be
gloom and glam cuz everything's gonna be
glittery and it's alright okay so that
was the trial run everyone feel good
about that I feel fairly good so that
was just practice cuz none of us know
how to do this none of us all of us
failed across the board not a single one
of us succeeded this is why we were
given two hands I feel like someone
they're gonna be mad for me saying so we
have another shot at this okay Tyler
stop put your ink down Tyler listen to
me
how are you never listen to me put it
down you two we're gonna go at this
again this time we'll get twenty minutes
does that sound fair Wow just one even
you know you have to start over
right and I know you're you're at the
advantage if you're gone that's
ambidextrous no mixed in same thing no
it isn't it is distinctly different
altogether of it being the same thing
say I it's 9:00
I'll post me the only person who has the
right to vote in this all right well the
only person with the right to vote
didn't vote correctly they said me
instead of nay the motion has passed
that was democracy in action
just because your democracy is a failure
as a government oh well that's another
tough all right so we're gonna try again
okay ready three two one haven't I
didn't think of a theme are you
confident yeah I feel good about this
I've got I've got an idea and I think
it's gonna come across like pretty cool
but I mean like well I need like hope or
something if it's actually gonna work
are you doing it are you doing the stamp
so you win it didn't what I didn't know
that okay your theme yeah I kind of but
it'll be okay it'll be even better now
it's okay okay sorry you just look bad
see the tricky part is to do more stuff
you got to wait for it to dry not me I
say full steam ahead
[Music]
don't look at him don't you dare is
everyone else doing it's done you
feeling confident better than I was last
time and such a new good friend respect
for people that do their nails I didn't
realize that it wasn't this hard well
good there goes that all right well that
lives in there
Oh keep coke going what you were saying
are you saying could I have a new friend
respectful people that do their own
nails cuz I didn't realize that it was
this hard to make it look good like to
do the styling so if I knew that was
hard but just like to get a basic coat
of nice-looking nail polishes card whoa
whoa all right thank you thank you I'm
good I'm done dude disqualified Tyler
that's just great why do we remove it if
we couldn't use the same hand what no
the rule was you had to use a clean
slate technically was a clean slate no I
made it up
the rule was you had to use the other
hand I was cleaning off so I didn't get
nail polish on everything I touched no
the rule was the other I had a clear
rule oh you don't know the rule because
you selectively choose not to listen you
were like I'm gonna do that hand I don't
care what anybody says I don't care I'm
gonna do it disqualified disqualified
right
all in favor of disqualification say aye
aye that was a third eye I heard during
the I count all posts say nay nay you
already voted No
disqualified did you clean off the nails
I did done yes
all right cool all the undecide
applicants put your hands forward up nah
no sorry that's
no sorry that's that's not that's not
that oh that's your hand of guts doesn't
get it so we've got an assortment of
pans here who's gonna present their
theme first I'll present my scheme first
my theme is beep basic sure is well done
and done in a timely manner you can't
get much more the--my than theme itself
bam bam bam bam thank you ma'am
next person there's there's markiplier
and if you look at it up side turn your
hand upside down it's Wade so mine was
going to be unicorns hiding in the
jungle that's why I did the green on the
leaves cuz I was like I'll put a unicorn
sticker and I'll try to get like it
through the gaps in the leaves the green
didn't pick up this is the green wasn't
a stamp abut I think I saved it with the
other like now it's like more of a
modern art style crosshatch kind of like
camouflaging the unicorns back there you
know what I mean oh yes and what oh just
Oh see it's pretty good theme I gotta
say I really nailed this symmetry on
this one especially so I could have done
a better job cleaning up around the
edges but uh not too bad for the first
time using the stamp technique and
that's everybody so uh yeah well what do
you think Ethan what do you think anyway
my theme was fine and shine everything's
unique everything special but adult has
this distinct wonderful shine I also
tried to make a game of Thrones like but
I ran out of colors for the houses so I
changed them because this was gonna be
jerseys house if wishes and wants were
blue sand blots everyone would have one
we didn't have nursery rhymes you I was
a kid can't or too poor can't influence
your theme with a want it did that's
that idea is disqualified alright okay
alright fine fine I'll allow it
just this once though every single time
you change the rules when we clearly set
out the rules and people just let you
get away with it
no one's outraged besides me why you
changed the rules [ __ ] you can't change
the rules no changing rules in front of
my rules that's what I'm saying that's
the way it should be
don't you ever was it clean slate
all right okay all right so what shall
we judge about okay these are the three
criteria who got had the best theme with
the best technical execution and whose
matches their own personality the best
is something that we're judging or is a
an unbiased judge judging amy do you
want to be an unbiased judge theme goes
to Ethan oh that's not you bear goes to
mark because of the the stamping closest
to the personality I think is time
because he's a cheater right because he
cheated because you changed the rules
it's the right a dirty rotten cheater
yeah I would like to remind you that we
don't all have to be winners
no that would fix the dirty rotten
cheater be my I'm okay with giving him
that one all's fair that ends fair okay
well but I think the lesson that we
learned is we're not cut out to be male
youtubers yourself I will say his there
pretty well done letters how do you do
the letters this oh yes you don't give
them too much credit okay how's your
calligraphy how's yours mate anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been another markiplier makes
they're slowly getting out of my control
I won't be able to contain the beasts
for much longer run while you still have
life in your lungs Thank You Ethan
you can find Ethan at crank game plays
Thank You Tyler you can find them in
Apocalypto underscore 12 and thank you
me for being Who I am and having the
patience and grace to deal with these
two idiots beside me I'm on Twitch
and thank you for watching at home if
you want to see more markiplier makes
linked in the description thanks again
for watching and as always see you in
the next video buh-bye bye